I am Benjamin couch pane I'm a project
officer with the Barney charter school
initiative and I'm also one of the
founding members of the Anna Julia
Cooper public charter school effort here
in Washington DC
welcome to the Allan P Kirby Center for
Constitutional studies and citizenship
which is the campus of Hillsdale College
in our nation's capital Hillsdale was
founded in 1844 with the mission to
furnish all persons who wish a
respective of race religion or gender a
liberal arts education specifically
aimed at developing the minds and
improving the hearts of its pupils the
man standing right over here knowingly
or not said all the events in motion to
have us here this evening and he can
also sing so as a result I'm not gonna
waste any more time this is mr. Roger
Moss jr. accompanied by Hillsdale
College junior Larina
Clements on the piano performing a piece
composed by Margaret bonds with lyrics
from a poem by Langston Hughes which is
the Negro speaks of rivers
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
who
and with that officially welcome you to
the second annual symposium on liberal
arts education and african-american
history a tribute to Anna Julia Cooper
and now I turn it over to a co-founder
of this event mr. David with him good
afternoon right so since we're
ultimately talking about the classics
why don't we start this afternoon and
see how many people have been practicing
their lat
ready so wait they got a few about about
Kyra Tay I got one Kyra there we go
sits hello in Latin and Greek okay so
I'm I am David with and I am currently
I'm an English instructor at Savannah
Technical College and I have the great
privilege of moderating tonight and I
want to start by thanking all the people
who made this afternoon I keep saying
this night but this afternoon possible
starting with mr. Benjamin Payne he
won't admit it but he did most of the
work to get this together everything
that we're doing today it started him in
fact in front of an elevator in the
school that he and I used to teach her I
used to teach it and he used to be the
director of when he stopped me in front
of the elevator after I had spoken at a
conference somewhere far away from
Savannah and he said you know that kind
of thing you would get this if you know
mr. Payne by the way he leaned in he
said you know that thing you do we
should do that here I said okay
so who wrote the grants and called the
people and we're able to have the first
annual symposium on liberal education in
african-american history last year in
Savannah Georgia and that was for
william sanders scarborough who i hope
in if you don't know i hope that you
will learn about him if you do know
outstanding and we had dr. michele
Roenick and
dr. Patrice Rankin of the University of
Richmond and dr. Michael Benjamin it was
outstanding event so we decided that we
had to do it again this year and and it
had to happen in how and I I don't I'm
not a superstition a superstitious
person but I knew that it had to happen
because everything that could go wrong
along the way went wrong along the way
and yet I'm still standing here right
now including even today when mr. Moss
and I had spent three hours sitting at
the airport while American Airlines did
some paperwork to get our plane off of
the ground so we've had quite the
experience so please a round of applause
for mr. Benjamin Payne
of course I also want to thank our
sponsors because tonight or this
afternoon
would not have happened without them as
well the Society for classical studies
classics everywhere initiative the
classical Association of the Middle West
and South their Committee for the
promotion of Latin the classical
Association of the Atlantic states of
course where we are right now the Allen
P Kirby jr. center for constitutional
studies and citizenship they all
provided the means by which we could
make this happen and so thank you very
very much to all of them I also want to
acknowledge some of our our guests
tonight we've met mr. Roger Moss and
myself and mr. Payne I do want to thank
of course our speakers and I'll
introduce each of them individually but
dr. Shirley Moody Turner who is at the
University of Pennsylvania we'd like to
say thank you and welcome to her dr.
Kerr Olivia Herren who is from Howard
University also we'll be speaking
tonight and I'll again I'll introduce
each of them in a little bit more detail
I also want to acknowledge dr. Mike Mo
Rocca who is the head of the Anna Julia
Cooper Episcopal School in Richmond
Virginia and some of the students from
that school provided only make sure this
collage of Anna Julia Cooper so thank
you for being here tonight and thank you
for having your students do this can I
please get a round of applause
outstanding work
I'm also pleased to say my wife
unfortunately could not be here tonight
she is Vanessa with and though and she
has done well she's she is she has
gotten me together and so that that's a
good start but she also among her many
talents is an artist and she painted
this oil painting of Anna Julia Cooper
specifically for this event and so I
want to thank her as well if we could
get a round of applause she can hear you
in Savannah oh alright well let's turn
to our first speaker and that is dr.
Shirlee moody Turner who is going to
speak to us tonight about the education
of the underprivileged Anna Julia Cooper
is commitment to transformative
education in our nation's capital and to
give you a little bit of background and
I have it on my phone am I one of those
people I it is dr. Shirley moody Turner
is a scholar educator and writer who has
been conducting research and teaching on
the life writings and work of Anna Julia
Cooper for almost two decades she was
first she was first introduced to
Cooper's writings as a graduate student
and found particularly in Cooper's
stated devotion to quote the education
of the underprivileged moody Turner is
the author of black folklore and the
politics of racial representation in
which she examines Cooper's relationship
to early black folklore studies and she
has published widely lectured and given
interviews on the reach and continued
significance of Cooper's work she is the
co-founder of the Anna Julia Cooper
Society the founding director of the
Cooper Du Bois mentoring program and in
2017 she worked with the moorlands
finger and Research Center at Howard
University to create the annejulien uper
digital collection she is an associate
professor of English and
african-american studies at Penn State
University and is currently a fellow at
the Hutchins Center for African and
African American research at Harvard
University where she is completing her
next book privately printed Anna Julia
Cooper and the gender politics of black
publishing so let's please welcome dr.
Shirley moody Turner
[Applause]
thank you can everyone hear me okay okay
no okay I need someone let me know okay
how's that it's better okay first of all
I just want to say thank you to Benjamin
as well just a tremendous amount of work
to bring this event together and along
with the larger initiative and I think
it's just really really exciting what
you're doing with the Anna Julia Cooper
public charter school initiative that
was wrong
charter school initiative and you know
I'm just excited to see how things
develop and glad to be to be here and to
be able to be a part of it and it's
really great to be here with this this
group tonight so many brilliant people
here it's this is really exciting I want
to take a minute and just acknowledge a
few influences on the work that I've
done I think this is a really important
practice I'm gonna give credit to this
practice of giving credit from the color
conventions project I don't know if
people have heard of it but one of the
things they do is always you know
there's one person standing in front of
you but there's a lot of people who have
contributed to that work and I think too
about the you know hashtags like black
women we want to make sure that we're
acknowledging the people who have
contributed so I just want to take a
minute and I want to first say yes Mary
Helen Washington was my advisor at the
University of Maryland she was a person
who introduced me to Ana Julia Cooper
she did the 1988 Schomburg addition of a
voice from the south and not too long
ago she actually sent me a biography
that was given to her by Paul Phillip
cook who did a very early biography of
Cooper and who Mary Helen passed it on
to me Paul Phillip cooked worked with
Lewis hutchinson on the Cooper exhibit
with Anacostia Museum and that to this
day is really some of the most
incredible foundational work on Cooper a
lot of what we are doing here with
Cooper talking about Cooper know about
Cooper
wouldn't have been possible without that
exhibit and without Paul Phillip cooking
without Louise Hutchinson and the
Anacostia Museum I also want to
acknowledge Vivian May she wrote a book
into 2006
maybe 2009 called Anna Julia Cooper
visionary black feminist and that book
is the most sustained treatment of an
udderly Cooper's larger body of work and
Vivian may was a student of Beverly Guy
chef tall who is Anna Julia Cooper
professor of women's studies at Spelman
College and she recalls Vivian recalls
taking a seminar with Beverly where she
got quote bit by the Cooper bug and so
once that happens like that's it you're
studying Cooper for the rest of your
life so hopefully some of you will have
that experience too and I also want to
thank Howard University the Moreland
Spingarn Research Center holds Cooper's
papers which we've recently digitized
through the work of Jo Ellen al-bashir
Lopez Matthews McKinney Johnson Audrina
I foe and you know it really it was that
was a labor of love and we we pulled
together we did it pretty quickly got
the papers digitized and now they're
available to you know a global audience
of scholars and students who want to
learn more about Cooper I also want to
thank my husband and my daughter who are
here they're also part of this process
my daughter helped me with the talk gave
me some coaching points told me to be
confident in brave so I'm gonna try to
do that and that's it so again I know
there's a long preface but I think it's
important just to recognize that this
work is cumulative okay so I'm gonna go
ahead and get started and this is my
clicker
I'm yes okay there we go
okay it is hard to imagine today what
was really at stake when Anna Julia
Cooper in the late 19th early 20th
century advocated for a classical or
liberal arts education for herself and
her stew
we have come in some ways to think of a
liberal arts education as those courses
we take in college while we are trying
to determine what our real major will be
or we might equate a classical education
with reading the classic text of Western
literary tradition and while reading
classic text is certainly part of a
classical education both classical and
liberal arts education signifies so much
more historically a classical education
signified a schedule study that included
grammar logic rhetoric arithmetic
geometry music and astronomy and a
liberal arts education was focused on
educating the whole person to think and
lead and participate fully in the social
political and civic life of a society
for Cooper to argue at the dawning of
the 20th century for access to a
classical liberal arts education for
herself and her students ran exactly
counter to the currents in the National
racial politics within the United States
and the local politics within Washington
DC nevertheless and at great cost to
herself
Cooper persisted in advocating for an
education for all grounded in the
liberal arts tradition and in the
process she transformed the shape of
black education in our nation's capital
born into slavery in Raleigh North
Carolina in 1858 Anna Julia Cooper rose
to prominence by century's end as one of
the most influential voices I'm racial
and gender equality in the United States
she was a nationally and internationally
renowned speaker author community
advocate and educator whose work
included her 1892 collection of essays
of voice from the south and challenged
systems of oppression and sought to
improve the lives of African Americans
as a child she attended st. Augustine's
normal and Collegiate Institute before
going on to earn a BA and MA in
mathematics at Oberlin College she
taught for almost four decades at Dunbar
High School serving as principal for
five of those years and in 1925 she
became only the fourth black woman in
the u.s. to earn her PhD when she
completed and defended her dissertation
at the University of Paris Sorbonne at
age 72 she took on the presidency of
Frelinghuysen Universe
a group of Community Schools for
Washington DC's black working-class
residents when she retired from her
position as president in 1940 she
continued to serve as an Institute's
registrar until well into her 90s Cooper
lived until 1964 a hundred and five
years almost all of what she devoted to
advancing educational opportunities for
african-americans but Cooper's life
story is so much more than an
accumulation of dates and facts it is
not just what she did but it is how she
did it at what cost and to what ends it
is not just what she accomplished but
what she overcame and what she made
possible for others indeed at nine years
of age Cooper entered st. Augustine's
normal and Collegiate Institute in
Raleigh North Carolina and it could be
said that that is where she staged one
of her earliest protests against
educational disparities she would go on
to confront throughout her life founded
in 1867 under the auspices of the
Freedmen's Bureau in the Episcopal
Church st. Augustine's offered
african-americans in Raleigh and
surrounding areas access to both
vocational and liberal arts training
this access however was not without its
gender disparities and Cooper had to
petition for admittance into Saint
Augustine's courses in Greek and Latin a
protest she would successfully enact
again when she found herself shut out of
the quote gentleman's horses when she
arrived at Oberlin College several years
later Cooper recalls of her time at st.
Augustine's
quote a boy had only to declare floating
intention to study theology and he could
get all the support encouraged and
stimulation stimulus he needed while a
self-supporting girl had to struggle on
by teaching in the summer and working
after school hours to keep up with her
board bills and actually to fight her
way against positive discouragement to
higher education
so here cooper identifies two critical
impediments to her educational
advancement one the attempts to restrict
her access to a full curriculum and to
the lack of structural and particularly
financial support for her educational
pursuits these two things will be
critical in shaping her intellectual and
activist agenda as she worked to pursue
advanced educational opportunities for
herself and others and I want to pause
here to note that
was not just that Cooper was protesting
the fact that she herself had to work
after hours in summers and to serve as a
pupil teacher at age 10 but it was also
as she points out the sacrifices that
were made at home in particular those of
her mother Hannah Stanley who Cooper
States even after emancipation was not
quote released from self-sacrifice and
many an unburdened butter crust was
eaten in silent content that she might
eat out enough from her poverty to send
her young folks off to school so later
in life when Cooper addresses the all
black male clergy of the Protestant
Episcopal Church in Washington DC she's
not speaking in mere abstraction when
she states to be plain I mean let money
be raised and scholarships be founded in
our colleges and universities for
self-supporting worthy young women to
offset imbalance the aid that can always
be found for a boy who will take
theology and she concludes not the boys
less but the girls more this pattern of
protesting structural inequalities in
advocating for social change and
transformation will continue as Cooper
translated her personal struggles to
gain an edge equal education into her
work as an intellectual activist teacher
and administrator in 1887 she moved to
Washington DC to accept a position
teaching mathematics and science at
Washington's only black high school the
Washington colored high school known
affectionately as M Street and renamed
Dunbar High School in 1917 in honor of
Pop poet Paul Laurence Dunbar founded in
1870 only three years after Howard
University M Street was a preeminent
secondary school for black education in
the country it offered rigorous liberal
arts education along with vocational
training to prepare its graduates for
trade jobs careers as teachers and most
notably for pursuits in higher education
in 1902 at 44 years of age Cooper became
the seventh principle of M Street high
school when Cooper claimed her position
as principal of M Street the racial
climate locally as well as nationally
was fraught and it only been six years
since Plessy vs. Ferguson had
upheld racial segregation and public
accommodation including schools and it
would be another 52 years before Brown
vs. Board of Education would make
segregation of public schools
unconstitutional so the entirety of her
career in public education takes place
under the shroud of legalized racial
segregation add to this a shifting
racial climate in the u.s. that saw the
political and civic gains of
reconstruction met with the resurgence
of racial violence and the withdraw of
federal support for protecting the
rights and lives of African Americans
indeed this is the error that saw the
ascendancy of the Booker T Washington's
watching Tanana statistically model for
industrial education Washington's
accommodationist approach which
emphasize training blacks for vocational
and trade jobs found enthusiastic
supporters among white philanthropists
and became the dominant though not
exclusive model for black education
running counter to this current cooper
in her position as principal continued
an expanded em streets tradition of
encouraging higher education among its
students as one of Cooper's early
biographers Paul Phillip Cooke explains
Cooper succeeded in doing what white
public schools in Washington DC had not
she prepared her students to pass the
entrance exams and gain admittance and
scholarships to the top universities in
the country under her leadership M
Street sent students to Harvard Brown
Oberlin Yale Amherst u Penn Dartmouth
and Radcliffe as well as prestigious
black colleges and universities such as
Fisk Atlanta and of course Howard her
students scored the highest in the
district on standardized tests and her
school her intellect and her
administrative acumen received
international acclaim when French
scholar Felix Klein touring US schools
at the invitation of Theodore Roosevelt
identified M Street as one of the most
illustrious schools in the nation in her
1934 history of Darbar high school
fellow intellectual activists in
longtime Washingtonian Mary Church
Terrell credits Cooper with the
transformation of education in
Washington DC Cooper she notes
instituted a liberal arts curriculum
began placing students at prestigious
colleges and universities and earned a
learned accreditation for M Street from
such esteemed institutions as Howard
University
she did this in spite of resistance from
the DC school board in the political
machine that opposed liberal arts or
classical education for
african-americans and she carried it out
at great personal and professional costs
as an anti Easton a former M Street
student during those days explained if
you could smell or feel or in any way
sense the aura of DC in those days you
would know that it would only that it
only took her daring and having her
students accepted and given scholarships
at Ivy League schools to know that the
white power structure will be out to get
her when for example the white director
of Washington high schools Percy Hughes
insisted Cooper teach the colored
curriculum she refused for at least the
third time in her life to accept for
herself or her students an inferior
program of study
instead she waged what she referred to
as the courageous revolt against a lower
colored curriculum for M Street High
School despite her best efforts and the
swell of support from local from the
local community in 1906 Cooper was
removed from her post as principal of M
Street when the board voted not to
reappoint her she was effectively exiled
from her home in Washington DC and she
was denied official recognition as the
educational leader she was as she
explained in a letter written from
Lincoln Missouri in 1909 I served as
principal of M Street high school for
five years in this work I had the
satisfaction of believing that I was
able to encourage the efforts of higher
development I could only say that my
labor in this direction met with
appreciative recognition from the people
I served but they are lowly and them for
the most part voiceless the dominant
forces of our country are not yet
tolerant of the higher steps for colored
youth so that while our course of study
was for the time being saved my head was
lost in the fray the M Street
controversy as just more commonly come
to be known is often boil down to a
debate between WB Dubois and versus
Booker T Washington this approach
however diminishes Cooper's courageous
role in advocating for liberal arts
education for her students as well as
the ways in which her gender made her
even more
Birbal and the ways in which racism
racism and sexism at the individual and
structural levels work to forestall
black education and really to dissuade
black excellence or try to dissuade
black excellence
after five years teaching at Lincoln
Missouri at Lincoln Institute of
Missouri Cooper was called back to
Washington DC and resumed her position
as a teacher at M Street though she
would never again service principal she
continued to advance classical education
for her students and to advocate for
recognition of their achievements in
1923 for example Cooper put on a
production of two scenes from the Aeneid
the production was exceptional for a
number of reasons including at the most
fundamental level as TC Jaji state's
African descendants pected to lay claim
to the classics Cooper students
performance not incidentally focused on
two scenes featuring Dido and set in
Carthage or modern-day Tunisia in North
Africa the African elements in the
player for grounded and as Monica and
dunno explains Cooper Africanized her
production of the need by using Egyptian
iconography in the set design and by
highlighting references in the script to
the presence and contributions of
Africans in the Western world as in
dunno concludes Cooper used drama as a
way of informing students performers and
audience about the larger contributions
of black people to mankind especially at
points of intersection with Western
classical civilization
thus illuminating a common ancestry and
showing black people with a world
history preceding slavery Cooper was
especially pleased with what she with
what the students and the community had
been able to accomplish with such
limited resources wanting to give the
students a recognition that they
deserved Cooper wrote to wew EB Du Bois
and sent him a picture of one of the
students as Hecuba so that he might run
a notice in crisis magazine Dubois was
editor of crisis at this time when Du
Bois failed to do so
explaining that the photograph Cooper
stun him was not particularly
interesting and that he had had quote
nothing of real interest about the play
except for the short notice that she
gave it and that the general public was
not quote much interested in that
Cooper fired back according to me Cooper
says and she quotes herself here which I
love she would do that no she was like
according to me and so she was like I'm
a source of authority here a thing of
beauty cut from the classic contact of a
people is interesting Cooper goes on to
mark that the students performant quote
illustrates some of the best work
accomplished in the Dunbar High School
and she notes our staging alone cost
several hundred dollars which is a good
deal for poor folks and amateurs I trust
you will give the readers of the crisis
an opportunity to judge for themselves
whether our effort is interesting
underlying quotation works and I don't
mean to I don't bring that up just to
point out that there was a tiff between
to burn Du Bois but it's really
interesting and I'm happy to talk about
that later
but more to point out the degree to
which Cooper was willing to go to
advocate for her students that her
students could claim participate in
engage directly and transform a classic
of Western civilization suggests one of
the many ways their performance
constituted an act of transformative
resistance as Vivian may assert Cooper
held to the conviction that all forms of
education should be sites of liberation
and she advocated a critical pedagogy
where students and teachers would eschew
models of learning based on rote memory
the uncritical reproduction of
information or facile imitation her
students performance thus served as an
example of how Cooper brought education
activism and art together as part of her
social change agenda and she sure
believed that Du Bois should recognize
this while working full time as a
teacher
Cooper also continued pursuing her own
education as well but again not without
challenges and roadblocks in 1925 she
traveled to Paris under the duress of
being fired from M Street to complete
her doctoral degree
though she had started her advanced
studies in 1914 at Columbia University
when her brother died and she adopted
his five grandchildren she put her
graduate studies on hold then because M
Street would not give her leave she was
unable to fulfill the residency
requirement to complete her degree at
Columbia University with the assistance
of Felix Klein who had written that
glowing review of M Street 20 years
earlier she transferred her credits to
the University of Paris so born where
she wrote a new doctoral thesis in
French on Frances attitudes toward
slavery during the French and Haitian
revolutions which she defended also in
French in Paris the heart of
intellectual you know French
intellectual cultural life so you know
and that's another thing we can talk
about later as well is the degree to
which Cooper was willing to go into the
space and you know this kind of seat of
cultural intellectual power and to talk
to them about what they needed to do to
recognize how slavery had shaped their
history as well and and her examiner's
you know took her to task for it and she
she took them to task right back later
in life Cooper would serve am I missing
a scene there's there's Cooper
that's her dissertation on the left and
there she is in her doctoral regalia on
the right later in life Cooper would
serve as president of Frelinghuysen
University founded in 1906 as a group of
community schools to provide continuing
education for working black adults in
Washington DC as leona gable explains
Frelinghuysen was an effort to fill a
serious need out of the seven full-time
universities in Washington there was but
one black institution and a list of 88
part-time colleges and special schools
not one would admit african-americans
when the DC Board of Education refused
Frelinghuysen the right to grant
bachelor's degrees and funds became
increasingly tight Cooper appealed to
the n-double-a-cp to support it
she felt it was the duty and
responsibility of the community to do so
when they did not
she moved portions of the administrative
and teaching services into her teeth
street home as Paul Philip cook states
breathing haizen served an important
function in Washington DC in its own
right while also propelling other
schools in the district to make
continuing and adult education part of
their curriculum as much as cooper rose
to prominence as my somewhat brief
comments today illustrate she was not
she was still and always working from
the margins and while cooper was
extraordinary she was not singular she
worked within a community of men and
women some of whom she closely aligned
others with whom she held productive
differences she accomplished much but
she did not win all of her battles
racism and sexism curtailed some of her
most ambitious projects she had wanted
to write a history of african-americans
in Washington DC who might be better to
write that history than Cooper but yet
she was denied funds for such a project
when she applied to the Brooking
Institute for support nevertheless the
legacy she leaves is greater than
defeats doled out on the basis of race
and gender she honored the humanistic
impulse and saw education as a vehicle
to answer the innate longings of each
individual for self-realization and
highest expressions of freedom she
believed that an awakening of the
individual consciousness could give rise
to individual and social transformation
she advocated for the ideological but
also material support for especially
black girls and women but for all people
dispossessed from seats of power and
privilege she advocated for wrote in
support of and utilized in her
classrooms a pedagogical approach that
pushed back against the dehumanizing
curriculum of the Machine age that
relied on efficiency and rote
memorization and was producing workers
instead of educating men and women she
transformed black education in DC by
creating a steady stream of black
students into the Ivy League's
I'm sorry I just lost my place
also and also by creating community
schools that put pressure on other
institutions to create continuing
education programs and by modeling and
inspiring at the very core of all of her
work education and service to the
greater good
[Applause]
thank you very much that was outstanding
I can't wait to discuss that our next
speaker is dr. care Olivia Herren doctor
dr. Herren is a highly decorated and
accomplished scholar and classicist
with accolades to numerous to list in
full at the moment but includes the
Elizabeth stone memorial award I'm going
to mispronounce it the back whole
backhoe lashauwn media award a Fulbright
fellowship and more she is an author and
educator and the founder of epic center
stories care Olivia writes fiction
nonfiction song lyrics opera and books
for children including nappy hair she
has held professorial appointments at
Harvard University at Mount Holyoke
College Cal State the College of William
and Mary and Arizona State University
she is currently a professor in Howard
University's Department of classics
teaching courses such as blacks and
antiquity and we were speaking before
this presentation I was telling her how
jealous I am of her students after I
looked at the curriculum of her courses
are really outstanding she also hosts
her weekly radio program epic City which
you can hear at 4:00 p.m. on Tuesdays on
Tacoma radio 90 for three she can be
found seemingly everywhere and anywhere
there are scholarly pursuits happening
in DC and dr. herons family has strong
and direct ties throughout our city and
particularly with dr. Cooper whose
influence inspires dr. herons work today
please welcome dr. care Olivia Hiro
[Applause]
thank you okay had to I want to start by
saying that so many of the names that
you use a new talk are household names I
grew up with with my grandmother and her
siblings and so forth all new and a
Julia Cooper they knew Terrell they knew
Mary McLeod Bethune it was like all the
educators in DC seem to be godparents to
my uncles and aunts so it's always it's
always weird to for me to switch my
brain oh they're famous out there there
but that's that's aunt Suzie you know
that's their close friends my mother
talks about being placed on the lap of
Mary McLeod Bethune and different little
things like that that are part of
growing up and rapport enough but I
guess you could say the the black
intelligentsia class if you will and in
Washington DC and I also wanted to make
a statement in an honor of Ben I said
your name wrong the first time now I'm
gonna make sure I get it right the
second time pain that I know you did
some work with in a classic school in
Atlanta and there are some problems
there what I want you to know the city
of Atlanta asked for to purchase 4,000
copies of my book nappy hair and and
seems to be rejecting the classics
having no idea that the book nappy here
was written as a part of my comparative
epic class at Harvard University in
which I taught the Iliad and the Odyssey
and all those kinds of books because
this is in a direct tradition of the
classical epics and so I just I felt
like I have to say that in case I don't
it doesn't fit in somewhere I want you
to know that as a group well I am going
to basically tell you about my family's
strive toward education and Anna Julia
Cooper will come in and out you I'll be
ending
talking about the harbor of Ethiopia an
african-american epic that I would not
have discovered if I had not been this
just inspired by Anna Julia Cooper from
Roanoke to Bridgewater I had an ancestor
of 1858 ran away from slavery in Roanoke
Virginia she had white skin so she
didn't have to take the Underground
Railroad to use the overground railroad
she actually was at a school for white
young ladies and didn't know that she
was black until she came home
unexpectedly and found out and her white
slave-owner father told her she was that
sort of thing
compromise was made mother and father
the slave mothers and the slave owning
white father she was given a bunch of
money put on the train went to
Massachusetts and lived among the
Wampanoag people Native Americans in
Massachusetts and made a decision she
was so mad about slavery that she was
determined to turn her family black she
said I have a little story come from
black from white to black and three
generations and she she she essentially
she was pretty oppressive it sounds like
to me all of her daughters marry the
cold cold blackest people they could
find and and and that's from whom I got
my wonderful nappy hair it's right now
but it wasn't always right okay
so so that's the beginning of the story
she was very much into you she was in
school when she found out about her
education having it essentially a
classical girls education and and my
parents both of my parents and my
mother's side in particular always
quoting latin phrases and things around
me I was a part of my life
my grandmother under Harpers Ferry which
of course we associate with with
revolution with John Brown and so forth
that's where she met my grandfather who
was from Jamaica and they married both
of my
grandparents graduated from college in
the early 1900s this is unusual for
anybody in the United States let alone a
black family to have two people
graduating from college so early and my
grandfather actually was a professor for
a short while historic college in West
Virginia they met at Hilltop house
someone who may have may have gone there
it's still there I'm told and I have the
white to black the three generations
okay I'm just listing some of their
friends Mary McLeod Bethune Anna Julia
Cooper
Eliza pearl shipping was she's the one
who created the deltas and she was like
my mother's got another he's household
name
Betsy Parker my mother just described
crying going to school every day because
she had to cross a railroad track out in
Kenilworth neighborhood here in
Washington DC and she had to go past the
white school to go to the black school
which is now Carver Elementary and
thinking about and her and her own
desire to be educated and and outraged
by even at that young age having to go
to school in that way my mother was a
graduate of Dunbar High School and was
there after energy Leah Cooper but knew
all about her and and of course it heard
about her through her mother my
grandmother as well and learned Latin
and studied Latin and was a Latin
scholar there and she even studied I'm
told and she did she used to recite
Chaucer middle English to me and that
sort of thing from high school it was
that Emma Street school that she met
Marian Anderson she met Eleanor
Roosevelt and you can read about that or
see that if you ever see my opera I have
but I made it into the Opera Marian
Anderson that freedom seeing the story
of Marian Anderson this is actually the
80th anniversary of her this year of her
concert on the mall in 1939 and we're
hoping to do something about that it at
Howard University
in April okay so
I'm I guess I'm gonna finish my parents
life and then I get to the energy Leah
Cooper in my life so bear with me my
mother graduated from M Street School
which was Dunbar High School by that
time and got two letters in the mail one
offering her a big job as they thought
in the federal government and the other
to go to college it was minor Teachers
College and her mother had always wanted
to be a teacher and every and everybody
said oh if you go into the government
you'll make so much money you'll be rich
you'll be this that the other and
everybody was begging her to go for the
government job and she said she went
into the bedroom and cried and cried and
cried and cried and her mother said you
know he want to be a teacher
go be a teacher and the whole family
capitulated as it were and she gave up
the rich job as it seemed to them then
and went on to be a teacher and through
through what is now the University of
District of Columbia and I can just just
to finish up that story she's still with
us in the world she's 94 years old she
became a super science teacher and in
Washington DC and I guess one of the
funniest moments of my life was when I
was a brand-new newly minted professor
at Harvard University where I thought I
was hot stuff I was walking across you
know the yard he thought I'm really
something you know and then some kid
comes comes running across the yard
professor here professor Harrison what
are you miss hurens daughter she had
taken science from my mother at
Lafayette elementary school and was
thanking me for my mother that's what
happens you know you can't follow after
some people okay well I surrounded by
all of this education and classic
education my father was in love with
epic heroes I'm I persist if you will
my nickname as the epicenter scuzz I am
always into epics and talking about epic
cynic and even when I'm trying to talk
about something else
talking about epochs and i can remember
walking my first contact with Anna Julia
Cooper we're just walking by her house
and seeing the area where she lived
because auntie Street is the house where
there are lots of elite black people
lived it I didn't live there I was I was
like you know second third fourth tiered
but but they were like the mayor
Washington married into the Bullock
family the Bullock's were pastors of my
mother's Church there at Baptist Church
Superstars kind of thing and I was
considered smart enough they had a
daughter I was considered smarter if
they would drink they would come all the
way out to Northeast and get me to come
play with their daughter cuz they wanted
their daughter to play with somebody
smart so that was that wasn't that was
my experience of T Street and so I would
go up and down T street and and miR
Washington you may know lived on T
Street 508 e Street I used to go in
there and play with mayor Washington's
daughter and and that was a part of my
life so I was a familiar with her name
then and there's a couple of scenes I
think of the concept of hiding you know
in order to learn this is the in fact
mean distill the energy Julia Cooper in
my life it's hiding somewhere so that
you could learn something I went to
Neville Thomas elementary school in
Northeast in Mayfair mansions
neighborhood and when I would when I
finished all the work for all sixth
grades by the time I finished the first
grade I just said in the corner for the
six years I didn't I didn't do much of
anything
I had to they didn't know what to do
there was no school they could send me
to and thinking about and I want to jump
to something you say about things are
coming to my mind you stirred so much my
father actually had the highest recorded
scores and IQ in Washington DC when he
and he and there was nothing they could
do with him they could there's no place
to send him no school no place no no
encouragement and no money he didn't
want to be a preacher and if you don't
want to be a preacher he had nothing he
hadn't no way he could go for further so
that that really struck me when you
talked about and that his education was
through
the Dunbar High School to that high
education very high education so hiding
to learn when we're supposed to be at
recess you know running into the school
and sneaking up to the sixth-grade room
and reading the books that you nestled
to be able to read yet and finish them
all up and I was my mind was in a way
was getting ready for the Anna Julia
Cooper story I feel that that affected
me so much in the research part of my
life because I when I found out that she
could they wouldn't let her learn Greek
and Latin which I wanted to learn so
much and I can tell you in my high
school Coolidge high school our Latin
teacher would not allow the black
students to come in through the front
door we had to go in through the back
door the the white students went into
the front door and if you wanted to
learn Latin we hadn't won it a lot
because you had to endure the insult of
going into the back door I remember
trying to go in through the front door
one she just stood there and wouldn't
let me through but I wanted to learn it
so bad that I put up with that insult
and winning through the back and she
would teach Latin four days a week and
on Friday she would teach Greek and I
actually preferred the Greek and so I
just wait for Friday so we could learned
a little bit of Greek and and that was
like a joy for me fighting to be
fighting to be educated there was a
person in my mother the neighborhood
where my mother grew up in Kenilworth
Charles Thomas he was actually the dean
of minor Teachers College another
product of Paul Cook and the people
you've been mentioning guy Paul Cook was
a good friend of my visiting him many
times and so it's just like I can't
believe you're talking about my friends
and okay so I didn't realize that
Harvard was a white basically a white
school because there was this black man
on our street everybody said was the
smartest man in the world
okay he's dr. Charles Thomas a very dark
skin and there was a job that I didn't
quite understand about him in which he
would there be a big occasion and
everybody would wear their robes and he
would wear his Harvard
which of course was red and there was an
idea then that the dark-skinned people
should not wear bright red and somebody
who didn't understand that Harvard was a
prestigious school said to somebody else
in the group why would they put the red
role born Charlie
cuz he's so still dark and it was like a
big joke in the family that this poor
stupid person didn't know that this was
an honor and that in this case the usual
don't let black people where we're at
red didn't didn't fit well I didn't
understand any of that I didn't
understand color isn't I was I was
clueless and I thought that meant that
you had to have really dark skin to go
to be the to go to the school where the
smartest person was the world so I
remember sitting on the wall across from
his house on the street and wishing I
was really really black so I could go to
this school called Harvard and and that
way I could I could go where the
smartest man in the world he used to go
I got to tell the story at his funeral
and share it for the first time with his
wider family it was a it was a lot of
laughter about that he actually visited
me at Harvard one time and my office
there before he died which was which
also enjoy so this is all the background
I want who I get to the what did Anna
Julia Cooper do in my life I was told
that there's no such thing as
african-american epic almost all the
genres of African African American
poetry occur for black people at the
same time as they occur for white people
and black people were writing romantic
poetry when white people are writing
romantic poem back and forth and so
forth and most American epics are
written around the Revolutionary War
and you don't find any African American
epic from the Revolutionary War so
people said they didn't exist and I just
felt like I was really depressed I felt
like the epic impulse is everywhere and
they has to exist and we'll get that
back when they need we don't need it
right right now and so I sort of
wandering around libraries and digging
up old things and happened upon energy
Leah Cooper's a voice from the south and
about her sitting in the back of the
room hiding under her table I mean she
was learning Greek under her table and
these well I don't see what board eyes
in my head in the front with the table
available to them weren't learning a
thing and she had it all and I thought
well I'm just going to take this from
her and I remember just reading that
mrs. I'm making the decision that
african-american epochs exist I'm
ignoring everybody who tells me he
doesn't exist I just decided it I I
don't care what they say
and so now okay where is where is it and
so I started going to libraries and and
I did instead of saying I don't know if
it exists and can I look at this and I
just decided that it that was there and
I went to the rare book room in Library
of Congress and and I got a wonderful
fellowship to the panicky library at
Yale couldn't find a thing there I found
I found I did find a book
18:35 there's my first clue that there
was something there 1835 john-boy wrote
an epic in miltonic blank verse from the
Bahamas called a vision aha
so if I if I feel a desire for this
other people must have felt it at some
times so let me find this stuff so I
couldn't find it and I got this
wonderful fellowship the Barna key went
up and down everything went through all
the catalogs nothing nothing nothing and
every day I would be in the library
feeling depressed because I was spending
their money and enjoying that part but I
could find nothing I would pass by these
great big piles of like card catalogs
that said miscellaneous miscellaneous or
so I said well I'm not finding anything
as I might go see what miscellaneous is
so I pull out the miscellaneous and lo
and behold some amazing person way back
when it's just collecting epic poems
from all over the place ten at a time
sticks him in a binder puts them on the
shelf and calls it miscellaneous and
like they're like a hundred two hundred
of them and most of them about white
people but I find like twenty by black
people and
just sticks him in there and it's under
miscellaneous and I'm thinking wow and I
found my stuff and it was like I think
Anna Julia Cooper was there you know I'm
I don't have to be a scholar like I
could be a novelist kind of person and
say I think there was a spirit there
helping me out and I couldn't believe
the joy I found with finding these these
epics and they're about everything under
the Sun they use some another Muse
Milton some of them use Homer
some of them use Germanic epics the the
foul story as their as their foundations
and elaborating stories about about
African Americans many of them use about
half of them use Abraham Lincoln as a
hero there is almost as if there's a
certain kind of sadness in this you find
them just struggling to figure out who
is the hero who is a hero and I have
this picture in my head that there was
that they were sitting on a wet at a
window and escaping slaves running past
the window and they're thinking who was
the hero and they can't see you know
that the hero was right there among us
and a part of them so many of them are
those kinds of stories but I can we get
there I don't know what happened to do
this the the one I found at the end by
Maurice Corbett sorry but it's because I
I wasn't using it enough so it didn't
like what I was doing among other things
okay called the harbor video Pia and not
only as I talk about the history of
african-americans and Africans in the
world
it's can I guess I can make it do
something okay yeah Maurice Clarett
there and if you if you look at a little
bit further it'll tell you the heroic
deeds of their leaders and and ancestral
progenitors or trials and difficulties
all sorts of wonderful things trying to
tell the African story the African
American story the Ethiopian story
but also in the rhythms themselves
finally getting away from Strictly
European rhythms and using some African
derived rhythms jazz rhythms syncopated
rhythms that sort of thing and it's just
a wonderful experience to go from from
night from 1835 to I'm sorry it's
nineteen to ten I'm forgive me I've
forgotten the exact years on there and I
anyway it's it's it's in the early 1900s
so so this I feel that's what is what
Anna Julia Cooper gave me and there has
to be the idea that there has to be an
African American epic and if you
actually I don't think I don't know how
to get to the to the page but if you go
back far enough let me see if I can find
it you know the you know we scholars
don't get much in this world but I the
entry in the catalog I'm sorry I don't
know how the computer says American
African American and epic that did not
exist before my work I just like yes
Anna Julia Cooper and I did that and
there yeah can you see it the word
african-american and epic did not occur
in the same place before this works this
is what she did this is what I did and
this is what I feel is the contribution
that I have I feel like I've helped to
make as a part of the tradition of
insisting that there is a classical
tradition in our and our culture in our
lives
and I me see I don't I think that is
what I've had wanted to share with you
yes thank you
[Applause]
right can you hear how you can hear me
okay I know you can hear me I if anyone
has a question please for either dr.
Aaron or for dr. moody Turner if not I'm
going to be selfish and ask all the
questions so hi thank you so much I
really enjoyed both of these
presentations and I have a question
about for both of you if you know this
but I think dr. MIDI Turner if you could
maybe answer first what was the
relationship between Anna Julia Cooper
and Margaret Murray in Washington
because I know that they were both
teaching Cooper was older I believe but
I'd love to because I know you kind of
drew out the tension between Du Bois and
Washington I thought what about the
women
thank you that's a good question I
haven't found a lot that documents the
two of them in direct conversation in
any way but they were definitely in
overlapping circles so Cooper was
working with wears Nazira the colored
women League in Washington DC color
women's league and I can't remember the
exact name they changed names but
eventually they come together and it's a
National Association of colored women's
clubs and so market where Washington was
active in that and so they would have
they would have been working together on
similar projects so I don't find
anything that documents an Abril
animosity what's interesting though is a
lot of people had one of the people
people have looked at as Mary Church row
and have thought well Cooper and Mary
Church I went to Oberlin together there
in DC this whole thing happens with M
Street Mary Church trial doesn't
come out and say a whole lot at that
time and why is that Cooper actually
replaces Robert Tyrell as after he he
moves on to a different position she's
principal right after him and so you
know there was all kinds of speculation
that that they didn't get along or that
their husbands but I'm hesitant about
that because I think there were all
kinds of politics going on and a lot of
the women ended up working together when
their interests and needs kind of
intersected and I I don't know that you
know for Mary Churchill I don't know
that would have done much for her to say
something at that point to come out in
defense of Cooper in that moment and I
find evidence later that they did work
together and that you know Mary Church
troll writes about Cooper as being this
transformative force in black education
when she writes the history of
Washington DC but one thing I'll just
say one more thing to that really
quickly is that the period of the 1890s
really sees this kind of meant of black
women's political and intellectual
activity and in some ways that gets
answered in like 1900 of those avenues
start getting shut down so Cooper gets
excommunicated from M Street Mary Church
Tyrell is having problems getting her
work published and printed and
mainstream press Pauline Hopkins gets
pushed out of colored American magazine
by the same kind of Tuskegee machine
that was behind Cooper's and I to be
wells gets ostracized in the
n-double-a-cp and so in some ways
there's this kind of reaction against
this okay this black way I don't know if
it's a direct reaction but they end up
having vehicles that have been open to
them for political activity kind of
curtailed and they start looking for and
finding alternative spaces to do that
thank you very much for your lectures
I'm really interested in the idea of the
miscellaneous folder and and also in
relationship to that idea of a
miscellaneous folder and what you can
find in that in particular surely when
you're digitizing the Cooper archive
then what are the other materials that
you found such as Cooper's autographed
album hers
yeah family you know they're the same
collection that Mary Washington the year
that she edited the 40 volume Schomberg
collection yeah it I did one of the
books for that I did the one on Angelina
world Grimke and to speak
sort of to your question although it's
not about Cooper directly of those 40
books 39 of them were of books that were
already finished the energy just had to
read the book and write an essay for it
of course the one I had to do was
scattered all over moorland Srinagar and
and New York City and everywhere else
and I had to pull it together and I
really had to fight with skip gates
because he wanted to call it the
Complete Works Evangel you know well
grumpy there's no way it could be
complete I was looking at the backs of
envelopes and turning an envelope inside
out and the napkins that were from from
you know coffee shops and I read all the
letters that she's the first lesbian I
know somebody found somebody earlier
than that that we know of
african-american lesbian where I saw all
the letters but she crossed out the
cheese and put he's in there for
publication well I didn't publish both
both versions they chose to publish you
know the most recent version of it but
but it's but if I can say that I tried
to get everything but there's no way
it's everything is there and and I I've
actually tried to get somebody needs to
go there and make a do a better job so
that we can call it complete but it's
not what I was thinking when you were
talking about saying you know just
making a decision then it should be
there so it has to be there mm-hmm and
that literally is a message like that's
a method of research you know I've done
that with Cooper a number of times where
I'm like they
she's working with Celestine buble who's
this famous French sociologist and there
have to be correspondences like they
have to be they have to be there you
know and so as a matter of like going
turning to the spot and you know looking
in unlikely places in archives but also
you know in attics and in conversations
like just in conversations you know
thinking about the conversations you've
had with your family and learning more
about Cooper and the tests more I know I
hear you and others like you if you will
then not too many I don't know does
anybody like you but but you know what
people are referring to these I realized
that the the background noise of my
childhood is a play as a novel as a book
as something I never built very church
about your fall asleep and you don't
realize these these are people that are
that are so important later on and and
as I get older they rise and rise and
rise and she was down the street and she
was she was my uncle Jackson I would
love to have drama then saying for
coffee shoppers or you know I don't know
boudoir anyway I have them all talking
together it'd be wonderful project I
just wanted to say one more thing about
your question because for me I'm the
next book I'm working on is called
shadow writings and so not called shadow
writing this was about shadow writings
and not only is it a matter of looking
for works that you know exist outside of
the published book like you were saying
the work you've done on our autograph
albums and the stories that they tell so
it's not only finding the items but also
the way you I've seen her autograph
albums before when I heard you give your
talk on them I was like wow and so
having new ways of reading these
materials to you know people say Cooper
wrote one book really voice from the
south but what about her scrapbook is
that a book Rosanna the book why can't
we count that as another book she cut it
she wrote articles for the Washington B
and Washington and the afro-american and
she cut them out and pasted them into a
book and the articles are all about
discriminatory practices
some workers about this machine age
production critiques of an kind of ROA
education and they're pasted over this
book that's telling the story of the
rise of Standard Oil and industrial you
know you don't think there's a
conversation you know and still learning
how to read these kinds of subversive
practices that they're doing to get this
materials and then the last thing I'll
say about that is it's also about
reading the stuff that doesn't even
exist and you know when cooper published
a voice from the south
two years later alice bacon the founder
of the hampton folklore society said you
know we are so excited that cooper has
another book on the way oh and did she
ever write it is it gone the the story
of washington DC that she would have
read what would that story be from Anna
Julia Cooper living her whole life you
know in DC but she didn't get the
funding and so she didn't write that
story though I think there's just a
whole different way of reading black
woman's yes no I have to add to that
because I that before Phyllis Wheatley
died we were told that she had the
manuscript of a second book I dream I am
dreams of going through through Boston
and digging up her grave and finding
them under her bones I got I found it I
got it and I wake up and I'm just here
in DC it was like if you get the
researchers book you got it and nothing
you can do about it you got it keep
wanting to find it mm-hmm
ma'am in the back thank you so much for
both of your presentations and my
question is for dr. Turner and it's a
two questions that I'm gonna pretend
linked together and the first because
though I think you mentioned that being
bit by the Cooper bug and I was recently
bit by the bug and I've read a whole
bunch of her stuff and there were two
things that stood out to me that tie
back to as we talk here as we're talking
about education today and the first one
is you mentioned that she kind of
rejects this rote memorization kind of
strict way that school was taught and
the reason that is interesting now is
when we
talk about classical education often
what people are talking about is they
think about the grammar the recitation
all that which is part of the classical
education and that Cooper espouses
classicism in the liberal education can
you talk a little bit about that
contrast between what she is pushing
back again with what she views as
classical with kind of what we talk
about now when we view classical and the
second question is I was really struck
in her writings by how going back and
forth you have writings that very much
fit with what everyone talks about when
we talk about black feminism and then
you have writings where she really
elevates and praises kind of the sphere
of domesticity and I don't think it's
just because of the period when she's
writing but she really views the the
home is this powerful tool that I know
she constantly opened her own home up to
her students and extended education but
could you talk a little bit about the
tension of how she reconciled kind of an
education for women with this emphasis
on the home and then how she viewed
classical education as moving beyond
this rote memorization even though we
often talk about that in relation to the
classical liberal education very very
good questions big questions so I think
you know we don't know exactly how she
was teaching you know what it looked
like in the day to day you know
curriculum in the classroom necessarily
but we have kind of glimpses into that
and I think the play is a really
interesting example for me of that right
like she there's a way in which okay you
you learn you know you need that you
need that the kind of grammar you need
the language to be able to engage but
that doesn't mean that you are accepting
that uncritically right or unconsciously
and so I think even looking at the play
is like okay you're gonna read me but
what you're gonna be doing is so
different right that I'm not a
classicist I need that put me in my
class
but you know what she chose to focus to
focus I think it's really important what
elements you choose to look at how she's
seeing you know teaching her students to
read in that that kind of do what kind
of against the grain maybe breeding of
that so I think that's part of of what
she was doing she also which is really
interesting is she one of the I came to
Cooper was I was doing work on the
Hampton folklorist and I found Cooper
hanging out with a bunch of folklore and
like you know Hampton Virginia
I was like wait what's Cooper doing in
Hampton Virginia like you know this
picture this kind of I can eyes picture
we have of her didn't really fit with
that model and yet there she was you
know in Hampton Virginia and when she I
love the story she goes to a meeting of
the Hampton folklore society they had
the president of the all-white American
folklore society William walls Newell's
addressing the students and he's telling
them that soon they will throw off all
their kind of particularity and they
will join the great race of humans you
know once they can kind of get rid of
all that kind of specific stuff and just
be human you know be human race so
Cooper gets up right after him and say
you know you should appreciate that
which is closest to you you need to
cultivate a respect for your own
traditions your own stories that which
is nearest and she tells them literally
there is material here as great as ever
inspired homer or Virgil and that is the
that is what is going to give life to
your engagement right and so I think
it's very different than saying okay
you're gonna read this and kind of
memorize it but she's really trying to
think about I think always she how they
embody that space and I think she does
that in her writing
you know people my my advisor of Mary
Helen wrote one of the lines that says
you know Cooper was kind of had this
elevated rhetoric and was kind of
speaking for but not always to kind of
working-class black women and a lot of
people have kind of taken up a curtsy
that and saying well she's talking cost
multiple registers you know she's always
talking across multiple registers you
know biblical allusions and references
her audience would have you know black
working class audiences would have
gotten that you know and so I think that
she knew ways to embody different
discourses and how to kind of speak
across registers in the home question
there's more okay I think she did I
think she she didn't wanna I think into
people who've read Cooper and know
Cooper you couldn't jump in and you know
fill in but I think she didn't want to
completely collect I don't think she had
a centralized visa this is mail sphere
this is female sphere but I think she
did want to say that their their
distinction it's not that you don't move
across them not that they're kind of
gendered binary spheres but that there
was something to be said for the work
that had to be done in the home that
that work was important right and so I
think that that but I think it I don't
think she kind of she's moving always
you know I don't think it's like
centered here I think it's part of a
very vast network of space across which
she moved yes Mac Weston is short we do
you mind talking a little bit more about
the you know the relationship over the
relationship on a driller Cooper had
with the classics
and here I'm thinking about Blyden right
if you recall in his essay on the
liberal education right he had a
distinct view you know
I don't know I mean I think it I think
she saw it as really critical as an
important way to I mean I think she saw
in one sense as a way to lay claim to a
certain kind of space and certain kind
of tradition that you had that to have
this experience in the classics give you
access to different kinds of venues in
worlds and I think that but I think she
also saw it as an important way to kind
of to answer that would she called that
singing something that humanistic
impulse but I again I still don't think
that it I don't think it was a
completely westernized view of it I
think that there were that she had maybe
a more critical consciousness toward
classical education but still I think
embraced it but I don't think embraced
down consciously yes obviously I don't
know as much about Cooper indirectly
ways but I know about her effect on DC
education so I guess I feel that's where
my I'd come into that to that question
because I'm the result of that education
it's all my parents and and I whatever I
didn't you know I didn't say everything
before when I discovered the
african-american epic and then I began
to do extend my discovery into African
epic I remember my first trip to Africa
I had to go through Paris and I went and
stood in the Sorbonne just to thank her
because I know she'd been there and her
way to a PhD and then went on to do the
other but a fund that question reminds
me of questions I get like when I
started my PhD at Penn and I told them I
was interested in Latin and Greek and
this sort of thing I remember one of one
of a very well-meaning professor into
the director my dissertation saying and
do you want to be the first black
classicist
and I'm thinking what you know and we've
been learning that every it was taken
for granted that we would be learning
Latin and it's because of Anna Julia
Cooper we all learned Latin from you
know we get I remember getting a taste
of it and and since in sixth grades and
then taking it as a regular class
starting in junior high school and the
problem I haven't answered the question
it was such a part of our lives
well I can't separate it from just going
to school and so you're asking for
specific information as if it was
something unusual when it actually was
one of the day to day life
everybody did Latin because she's the
one who brought that and I didn't
realize that at the time but it was a
part of our lives as I said my I
remember my grandmother singing Latin
songs as I'm sitting there doing my math
or geometry homework just singing Latin
and and my mother doing the same thing
she has or some Latin poems I still
don't understand I gotta give you that
she learned which and she recited Latin
you know just like that and some of the
I mean maybe maybe more than I really
excuse they have like the Latin speech
at the end you know and my brother did
the Latin speech for her high school you
know and that was like normal it was not
I have a question that I'd like to tack
on to that because I think I heard some
things that that raised for me some of
the questions that have been in my mind
for a very long time throughout this and
that's so when when we're you know you
mentioned for example almost being
dissuaded right in in your pursuit of
studying classics that's certainly the
story that seems to repeat itself and
then you mentioned as well Cooper and
and her sort of her more global view of
looking at heritage and history and
classics and and so what I'm wondering
is how do you
how do we how do we create a just
curriculum a curriculum that integrates
you know western heritage and and things
like this with with the african-american
experience with the great authors and
the with people like Anna Julia Cooper
and Du Bois and what does that look like
bringing those two together because
that's what we're doing right now so I'm
wondering what does that look like now
do you think to bring those two together
at k12 level as well as at the
University in college web yeah well we
talked about that sounds like
yesterday's conference doesn't it
yesterday at the Center for Hellenic
studies in which we we dealt with these
same these similar questions and one of
my responses is you know you have some
wonderful wild-eyed afro centrists that
are gonna turn everything black that
they're crazy off on the side I love
them but you don't have to love them but
you don't have to go there you can go to
your normal regular classic people they
have all kinds of black people in there
that you you classicist I don't know
who's out here you've never mentioned
and and that's what I was saying
yesterday let's go say again you don't
you know the idea that and that in Arvid
Andromeda is black and I've never heard
and I've been studying classics all my
life and nobody ever told me this you
know and I asked my colleagues how would
you know did you know
and you never thought to tell her and it
says something that hadn't occurred it's
not ill meaning it's not racism it's
just not realizing it makes important I
love the classics whether they're black
folks in there and that I have gymnasts
I love it but I'm delighted to know that
they're all kinds of black people that
are black Oh black army went to
different Troy and it's not and it's not
in some wild because it's not it's not
off on the periphery of scholarship or
it's in the center though someone else
and why does anybody mention it you know
Mises the classes don't don't mention
those because yeah because it's it
develops a place in the curriculum in
the nineteenth century where it is
European heritage
so now we have to pretend like it's
nobody else yeah yeah I mean I guess I
would just reiterate that I think you
know the one of the things when Cooper
did her dissertation on the French and
Haitian revolutions just putting those
two things together the French and
Haitian Revolution like the French
weren't really trying to do that
you know European history is kind of
separate from what's happening in the
colonies and and so by saying no no
these things are completely mutually
constitutive you know so I think it's
not just a matter of what it's really
important I think is diversifying the
curriculum is important and I think the
work you're doing it speaks to that like
you know now we can find African
American epics but it's also the way
that we read like how are we reading
these texts how are we constructing so
it's not just a matter of diversifying
curriculum which is important but it's
also then what is the lens you know we
can't just put them on there and say see
we've got the Western classics and then
we've added a couple other yeah that's a
different issue and we need to do that
we need to add things as well but but I
guess one thing that struck me I don't
know what got into me didn't take on
teaching this course blacks in antiquity
because I didn't know any better so I
took it on and it's like every week I
find something new it last semester it
seemed like every week I would come in
with some absolute fact and the student
would say well what no actually I
learned last week and they were right
and I was wrong yeah I used three basic
text Snowden's burnell's okay like I've
seen that and Mary Lefkowitz they
refused to buy my question was for dr.
moody I recently discovered the book
they knew Washington they knew Lincoln
by John Washington and I thought about
what you said about Cooper's desire to
sort of write this history of
Kym's in DC do you know if they were a
part of the same circle did they know
each other I'm sure your family probably
knew John Washington he was a teacher at
Cardozo high school in the 1930s 40s I
guess the book was published in the 40s
and went out of print by the name of
Kate Mazur who's a history professor
somewhere in Illinois got it back into
print very recently in 2017 so I'm
curious if they were I'm not sure
they're those circles are pretty close
you know they might have overlapped but
it would be interesting to trace those
two histories and see how he wrote that
book what kind of funding and support he
had to do it this woman Hannah Wallinger
has done that with Cooper and Dubois
kind of tracing the different levels of
support they had to do their projects
and how their careers kind of took such
different directions and why sometimes
people will say well yeah Cooper and
Dubois I mean they're not really on the
same because Dubois was so much more
prolific you know but when you start
looking at like where the funding and
the support institutional support
resources there's reasons why someone
might have been able to publish a
history and someone else mm-hmm might
not thank you
[Applause]
okay thank you all so much ladies and
gentlemen I think I just wanted to say a
few words thank you so much wonderful
discussion I look forward to continuing
it as we move on I think the thing to
point out is that this is a long
discussion that's been going on for
dozens hundreds of years and we're still
in it and the reason why we still have
to have symposiums like this the reason
why we have to recall and in Julia
Cooper I'm so thankful for these
wonderful people for bringing continuing
her story is because there's still going
on and that we still have we still have
an access and an equity issue in
education and even his recent is 2017
when a Classical School with
predominantly african-american
population is told that your curriculum
is not appropriate for your student body
and that part of it is intentional and
part of it is just not understanding and
so we're quite blessed humbled to be
among all the wonderful people in this
room and to continue an udderly a Cooper
story through the Barnett charter school
initiative through this charter school
effort in Washington DC no better place
no more appropriate place to push this
forward so thank you very much before
you leave we have another treat from mr.
Roger Moss jr. and miss Lorena Clements
another piece I inspired with the words
of Langston Hughes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you before I close I've I've
gotten a little bit of credit up here
but I want to pay a special credit to
miss Ashley Fraser running the show here
at the Kirby Center so thank you so much
this wonderful event so Anna Julia
Cooper aimed at fighting for the rights
of all but particularly for those who
have writhed under a mighty wrong and
she believed the most essential battle
to be won was in the provision of such
an education to our children a schooling
described in the Pollan following
passage from her essay on education
needless to say in this quote we're
using the all-inclusive version of men
in a word we are building men not
chemists or farmers or cooks or soldiers
but men ready to serve the body politic
in whatever avocation their talent is
needed this is fundamental no sort of
superstructure can endure on any
different foundation the aim of
Education for the human soul is to train
a right and to give power and right
direction to the intellect the
sensibilities and the will thank you so
much for coming have a good evening